le président de la république monsieur
mitterrand a regagné paris hier soir à
présent voyage africain qui l'a conduit
du zaïre à la république centrafricaine
en passant par le burundi pour le 11e
sommet entre la france et les pays
africains francophones retour d'afrique
le chef de l'état s'expliquera sur sa
politique avec cette région du monde
dimanche soir avec nos confrères de tf1
au cours d'une émission spéciale les en
marge de la diplomatie et du sérieux de
la politique
nos envoyés spéciaux comme nous n'avons
pas résisté au plaisir de vous montrer
cette image de françois mitterrand
ouvrant le bal avec madame kolingba les
pousses du président centrafricain
constater que le chef de l'état ne
s'attendait manifestement pas cet
honneur
la semaine remplie de bonne grâce cette
obligation sur des rythmes afro-cubains
interprété par l'orchestré les forces
armées centrafricaines
ok
rappelé
ouais
m
voilà les spécialistes des rythmes afro
cubains